okay I should really start to win the
odd game here my reading gets really
embarrassing to 380 oh my god and then
they play this kind of opening air where
you can never win with black if white is
somewhat competent
[Laughter]
what why can I not take the big sent
upon you cannot seriously believe that
this is enough compensation for why
draft okay if I go here like to have six
[Music]
naoki okay this that is actually not
that easy I know it sounds very strange
but he has a bit of compensation in this
position what a weird game yeah
something to g5 Bishop g5 95
yes compensation yet it's just what it
is
you know if he if he goes for that
battery I can go at five with not with
much enthusiasm but that's what I have
to do
[Music]
not in a million years I would have
played that move yeah that's for me not
so bad
this one I don't know I need to get rid
of that bloody night and that night
drives me crazy only five and now I
could go night she's six instead of f5
one night a night f5 s not go to work
not just 695 yeah yeah what is which is
not not the happiest move ever but
yeah how am I ever going to move that
bishop on CH that is the the question
night f7 maybe blah
yeah maybe even rupees seven dis work
its net not completely out of the
picture
you
or to g6 to be 6f night I'm threatening
mate this is coming with the temple that
is kind of that it's nice actually
maybe I'm okay I don't know
Knight f4 we cannot take it do I miss
something
some stupid trick like I usually do I
don't see it he cannot take it's
basically made only one an 92-93 should
win the house okay yeah that is a really
here give me back I thought he would
play Bishop c3 check by the Queen c3
chicken and chicken
here don't really see anything great for
him
my king is safe now
that was very scary at the beginning
very scary
do people come up with stuff like that
like 95 and then they just sacrifice a
biggie for porn
why does stuff like that yeah don't
sometimes I really feel I have no clue
about this game okay so I take the
center pong cookie form take and maybe
but should be 6s crap or something
Knight takes d4 okay that that I
couldn't come up with and then see
success this is like this is crazy with
all those pieces and it's equal and here
it's not equal I mean he's got a huge
attack it's got a huge attack well
should be three I'm not surprised that
this is great for white according to the
computer I mean it doesn't have any
depth at the moment but it looks
terrible
Bishop c2 was a bit stronger it still
looks bad look III yeah that was that
that I didn't really expect Bishop f4
I'm just attacking I don't get this and
I don't get this untangled it's just so
so bungled up really remarkable
I mean here I'm still in trouble for
sure then what did he do take on the 6m
yeah I'm still under pressure and it is
not as bad as it was but at least
objectively it seems to be like I'm out
of the woods now threatening only one
that's in a really important tempo and
then he stumbled into this one yeah here
I thought he would give check on on c3
and then and then okay I have creature
of six of concern yeah then it is really
not good
Queen d4 takes a form you should try
that that's still in a blitz game this
is so this is still a point I mean okay
this I would have would have found but
yeah that's not winning or anything is
just that should still continues and
here I'm basically really a rook up or
nothing much it's really a sort of weird
opening I mean of course after 95 I can
take it and have no problem that is kind
of obvious but like just do symmetry but
I wanted to do things this is why I went
here it assists it's really really
dangerous I mean those attacking ideas
are well known from the rubenstein
system where black plays this yeah it's
kind of its kind of comparable hmm yeah
it's very comparable maybe white was
really am planning this ahead him I
wasn't like an inspiration I mean this
is probably ending this line just in
terms of being interesting but it's also
very uninteresting for black
okay thanks a lot for watching